Ivanka Trump Donald Trump's 35 year old
daughter and White House assistant
advisor is Jewish by conversion so she
married Jared Kushner who is Jewish and
she converted to Judaism and like with
many things that do apply and many
things that don't apply to the Trump
children and family Ivanka is much like
her dad clueless she showed up on Fox &
Friends and she talked about this
completely embarrassing and bizarre trip
that Donald Trump made to Saudi Arabia
and Israel and Vatican City to visit the
Pope and she sort of intimated that they
covered the three major religions of the
world during that visit one of those
being Judaism now before I play the clip
for you converting to Judaism is a
pretty involved process you have to
become invested in what you're doing
Orthodox Jewish rabbis which is the
flavor of Judaism that Ivanka Trump
converted into based on Jared Kushner's
of Orthodox Jewish background Orthodox
Jewish rabbis I are known to be
particularly difficult when someone
wants to convert to really ensure that
they really want to convert you go
through a certain amount of education on
Judaism and a series of rituals it's not
a short process it's not an easy process
and it is taken really really seriously
so you would expect someone who has
converted to Orthodox Judaism to have
some basic knowledge about Judaism and
the prevalence of Judaism around the
world
evanka showed up on Fox and Friends
reminiscing about her trip overseas and
then said something really really odd
take a look at this really it's hard to
for each of these moments it's hard to
find the words to adequately describe
them and then to move on to Rome and to
meet with the Pope so to have covered
the three largest world religions over
the course of four days it was it was
deeply meaningful so again she's
referring to Trump went to Saudi Arabia
which covers Islam Trump went to Israel
which is a
Jewish country and then he went to Italy
in Belgium which are mostly Roman
Catholic so again to have covered the
three largest world religions over the
course of four days it was very
meaningful what on earth is Ivanka Trump
talking about and if we put up the list
here of the ten largest religions in the
world you will notice that Christianity
has 2.2 billion people of course
Catholicism only a fraction of that in
Roman Catholicism only a subsection of
that so there's some questions there but
okay we'll give her that Islam 1.7
billion people Oh
Hinduism 1.1 billion well Judaism must
be forthright wrong Buddhism 488 million
followed by folk religions 400 million
followed by Taoism one hundred and
seventy three hundred and seventy three
million people followed by Shinto one
hundred million people it's not looking
good Pat you'll notice 10th on the list
Judaism with only 15 million estimated
Jews in the entire world here's the even
better part it doesn't even seem like
Fox News knows what the hell Ivanka
Trump is talking about because they're
promoting the fact that she said this I
can't believe they've not taken this
tweet down Fox News tweeted Ivanka Trump
reflects on the president's first
foreign trip to have covered the three
largest world religions over four days
was deeply meaningful Fox News is
promoting the fact that she went on and
made this total fabrication about world
religions okay so I'm going to defend
Ivanka Trump a little bit here now Coxon
friends okay because when White House
press secretary Sean Spicer announced
the trip he said that Donald Trump would
be visiting the headquarters I guess of
the three greatest religions or three of
the greatest religions okay and maybe
she just confused the words greatest
with largest this is pretty thin okay
that's a pretty pretty damn thin thin
defense of this okay this is actually
kind of a common misconception about
Judaism and it's connected with lots of
confusion about many issues related to
Judaism Jews represent under 0.2% of the
world population I have a really hard
time talking about
the israeli-palestinian conflict with
people or issues about anti-semitism or
discrimination with people who just have
no idea even ballpark how many Jews
there are I'll often ask people who
start to say strange things related to
Jews which lots of people do by the way
what portion of the world do you believe
is Jewish and I'll get answers like 5%
10% even as high as 20% if you say that
5% of the world is Jewish you were
overstating the Jewish population not by
5% but by 25 times by 2500 percent if
you say 10 percent of the world's
population is Jewish you are
overestimating the population by 5,000
percent and for people who believe 20
percent of the world who believe that 20
percent of the world's population is
Jewish you were overstating that by 100
times how can we have a real
conversation if you believe there are
100 times more Jews in the world than
there are that's like wanting to talk
about American poverty and you say
that's a real big issue by the way how
many people do you think live in the
United States it's like if someone says
I believe the US population is 3.2
million well how are you going to really
be able to assess the scope of poverty
if you're so off or if someone says I
believe we we need to talk about poverty
in the context of an American population
that is 32 billion it's nonsense
and it's the same thing here well I mean
Judaism is the second largest religion
in America only behind Christianity of
course and you know that gets a little
bit confusing too because so many Jews
are secular yeah so maybe she's just
kind of locked into this American
perspective I think that could be
another defensive Ivanka you're just
certainly digging deep there okay and
and I think that you're doing a an okay
job at it but I I think that you're
trying to defend the indefensible so
okay I was okay you're kind of in the
role of Sean Spicer here right which is
trying to defend things that are
completely not defensible